what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to how
to
text women by alpha male strategies
another feel good
video i'm sure it's just gonna
be great um but before i start do not
forget to like
comment and subscribe as you guys know
i'm trying to hit 15
000. i tried to hit it last week but i
didn't get it so i'm trying to hit it
this week so if you like my content and
you want to like
do me a solid feel free to subscribe
okay this guy i hate watching his videos
sometimes but
i like to text and not talk on the phone
video on youtube
what's up fellas so today we're here to
break down the text game
and i know a lot of you guys been
needing this text game and [ __ ] i got a
phone strategy video on youtube but this
is a little bit different
and a lot of the young guys been asking
me about the text game
i get that most women like the text now
i really don't like to talk i get that
that's the era we live in right now
it's not true i would much rather talk
on the phone than
text we got a short attention span and
[ __ ] like that and it's easy for um
[ __ ] to juggle five to ten dudes so
for all you guys wondering like why
women like to text and not talk on the
phone
it's because so they can text 10 digging
texts back and forth between 10 [ __ ]
dudes that's why they
that's 10 guys at the same time
well a lot of you guys are running into
that all right they can't talk to 10
different dudes but they can text
10 different dudes all right that way
they can get their attention from 10
guys
at one [ __ ] time so guys well you
know the texas
is is uh the gift and the curse
the guilt feels you ain't got to talk to
those annoying ass [ __ ] all right
that's the kid you ain't got to sit down
and you know here they [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] all the [ __ ] day and [ __ ]
like that so that's the guilt
the curse is you don't build up that
rapport
and so you might you more liable to get
a flake
all right because she had she doesn't
get a taste of your personality
so let's say hypothetically you met a
girl at the club or at the [ __ ] mall
or whatever right
and so you know the phone was to build
up a little rapport
to where she started to like your
personality guys looks only
mean so much to women maybe like 30
percent person
that's very true like
i would even say less than 30 percent
probably like 20 percent
that's it maybe mean 30 and you know
what you're doing with your life and
[ __ ] like that
probably means like 30 or whatever the
case may be so i'd say like
50 what you're doing with your life you
can fraction each one of those in there
33
33 for 33 finances personality
looks all right and so with you being
able to talk on the phone you're able to
use your personality you can't use your
personality
through text and i'm and you know if you
try to be funny through text guys
i'm telling you you don't know how
somebody might interpret it too all
right so they might take it wrong you
might have meant it one way
but when [ __ ] gone through on text it
might come out another way to where you
were saying something nasty or saying
something you know that sounded vulgar
so please do not try to be a joke man on
the [ __ ] uh through text messages all
right
it's not that's true except voice memos
i feel like voice memos are
kind of a caveat way to go now i got my
[ __ ] notes
because there ain't no way in the hill
once i started talking and trying to
break down each talking point and
explain these talking points
i already know i was gonna forget where
the [ __ ] i was at all right so when i
whenever i do a video like this that i
know i got a lot of talking points to
explain and [ __ ] like that i make sure i
get my notes
because i know you guys take this [ __ ]
serious all right i'm pretty much the
mouthpiece
for all the guys around the world who
take this [ __ ] serious all right
so the first thing you guys need to know
is i
categor categorize uh the women you text
in two categories high interest
and low interest all right because
you're gonna get two
different reactions from each one of
those groups all right guys
so first off the back the high interest
girl
you take her out on saturday or whatever
the case may be or let's say you got a
her number at the mall saturday she
probably either text you that night or
she gonna text you the next day
all right she more than likely she gonna
send an initial text the real high
interest girl all right
not all the way not all the times all
right but if her interest is crazy high
it's more than likely she
uh sent an initial text and the thing
with this is guys that first text
you want to respond to it three to four
hours now
here's the thing guys i you know i've
been saying this for the longest
i don't want you sitting at the house
playing video games looking at your [ __ ]
[ __ ] phone talking something lms said
takes this [ __ ] back in
three to four hours i tell you guys to
be on your purpose be dating other women
have a social life for abundance so i
want you to thoroughly
be busy really be busy i don't want you
to be bullshitting all right
this is the thing what i tell you guys i
want you guys to live a social life of
abundance
be on your [ __ ] purpose date of the
women all right
it's more than just being on your
purpose i want you dating other women i
want you enjoying time with your friends
i want you [ __ ] busy i want all my
guys out the [ __ ] house feeling sorry
for themselves
and outside [ __ ] these hoes to sleep
and on a purpose all right
this is the cost to your soul
okay i want you guys genuine high value
males which means that
you have a very busy schedule and
obviously if i'm on a
i really don't like the term high value
because
you have to remember like what is high
value to you
and especially with women with like
personality and like
drive being such a big thing for women
like it really depends
on the guy and the girl like what they
have
in common and what their values are
like yeah i don't know
a date with another girl i'm not about
to stop doing what i'm doing to take
some girl i met two days ago
back all right she'll have to just wait
to the dado all right i'm on a [ __ ]
date right now
all right and another reason why guys
you don't want to be stopping what you
doing to respond to people texting [ __ ]
like this
because let's say hypothetically you out
with a girl and she see that you
responded to texts on a date with her
well when she takes you she probably
gonna be wondering like well what the
[ __ ] take you three four hours to
respond in my text it seems like you
have no problem
stop doing what you doing to respond to
text all right guys so understand that
disgrace is always watching when you're
on a date with a girl
and then you go to responding to text
right away but you take three four hours
of responding my text
okay so she already know you full of
[ __ ] all right cause you do
stop what you're doing and respond it
takes all right so
never respond to text while you're on a
date guys you won't want me to know that
when you doing something else that's
what you doing and she's just gonna have
to wait all right
that's the thing with that so a woman
with high interest he initiate contact
things like this this is what a lot of
guys mess up after you
respond to the initial text guys do not
try to wait another three four hours to
respond to the next text
okay all right the thing with this is
you want to respond after you broke
initial contact now you can respond back
every five to ten minutes all right you
don't want to respond back in 30 seconds
are they like timing these it sounds
like way too much work
it's after you know these texts all
right because that's too too [ __ ]
available
but five to ten minutes you want to
respond back to the text all right
and you'll see a lot of guys they try to
go do three four hours again
so guys here's the thing
women have a natural abundance mindset
all right
they ain't like most guys pretty much
every girl that looks halfway decent
have an abundance mindset
all right and she's getting hit on by
other guys all right
but for whatever reason whether it's the
way you look the way you walk the way
you talk something about you she got
high interest in you
all right now a woman gonna go start
thinking to herself
i got all these dudes trying to [ __ ] me
why am i sweating the dude who's
responding to my text three four hours
after each [ __ ] text
all right do y'all guys get that uh he
responded back
then he took four hours to respond back
i responded back then he took another
four hours to respond back
do y'all guys get that so a woman gonna
start to think that i'm dealing
dealing with a dude who has low interest
guys
uh women have a natural abundance
mindset they just gonna move it on they
have a natural abundance mindset
because they always got somebody trying
to get in their pants so anybody who has
it like that unless she's a girl that
looked like [ __ ]
but if she if she's a seven and above
she got
dudes that's trying to get in her pants
so her natural instinct is
why am i gonna run behind a dude who
ain't really trying to you know
show me any kind of interest all right
so you know after the initial
uh this is a lot of like time
and energy spent on like
how soon you should text a girl like
i did i can't believe guys actually
think of this stuff takes
you can respond back every five to ten
minutes to after each text all right you
don't
listen don't run that game on a girl
with high interest guys i'm just telling
you that [ __ ] now i've done that [ __ ] in
the past and tried to do all that [ __ ]
and try to add like i was too
unavailable and [ __ ] like that each time
the girl lost interest
you can do what the [ __ ] you want to now
am i saying this is going to happen to a
girl that's like a five or a six
probably not
but is she a eight nine or ten guys and
you try some [ __ ] like that and she got
50 dudes trying to get enough pants
let's see how that work out for you you
hit me back and you let me know how that
worked out for you i wanna see how that
work out for you that's not gonna work
out for you guys
anybody who got options ain't gonna take
no [ __ ] like that alright
so now that you responded back every
five to ten minutes
you know all right so never set a date
on the initial text all right so let's
hypothetically say
y'all ain't going out yet let's say you
met her saturday and she hit you up
before
you hit her up because i tell you guys
to exchange numbers
all right say she hit you up all right
don't set a date right then
all right don't set a date you want to
wander a little bit
you you can get to know each other a
little bit back and forth through the
text or whatever the case may be
but don't set a date right then you let
off the hook too [ __ ] easy all right
okay this is why i would disagree with
that
especially if you're young and you're a
girl that's like met a lot of
like got like what are you saying like a
girl that has like 50 guys after you
like if like i think guys wait too long
to plan a date like a lot of people
would just rather like
meet in person and like start getting to
know each other rather than like
have a whole like texting conversation
before like it's not fun
because she's thinking oh hey damn i
want to see him again that's what i want
you want to build that anxiety you want
her ass thinking this is what's gonna
make her fall in love with you
because now she has something to think
about he ain't asking me out
that's what you want all right you don't
want you your ass out yeah let her ask
one a little think on it
that thinking about it why she ain't
with you cause she's gonna be thinking
about it when i'm gonna see him again
this that another because she don't want
to ask you out
you know she you know if she got crazy
high interest or something like that she
might say
you know so when are you free oh uh you
got a lot going on she might try to
initiate to push you to ask
but unless she asks you out you're gonna
hold that card let him wonder let's
sleep on it all right that's what's
gonna build that anxiety
this anxiety is what causes women to
fall in love guys all right
so i know a lot of you guys when you you
know you do things
you want to show a woman's certainty all
right certainty to a woman
is the opposite of love all right women
fall in love with uncertainty this is
why i tell you guys don't validate women
all right
because when you validate them you're
giving them certainty and so when they
get certainty they start
feeling themselves and then they started
turning little [ __ ] alright you want
them
uncertain uncertainty that anxiety is
what causes women to fall in love with
you all right you don't want women to
know where you they stand with you
all right okay i like how all the guys
giving this
advice i guarantee he's not married
because in a long term like my parents
have been married like almost
30 years and i can guarantee that
neither of them have anxiety
that the person's gonna like leave or
not be interested
i mean that might be you know successful
in the short term but like
if you want a long and happy
relationship and that's how you're gonna
treat people
good luck okay so now here's the thing
guys
um if a woman with high interest
is um hasn't is initiating contact
it's okay to go back 50 50 uh on the
initial contact so let's hypothetically
say
you met her sarah that she hit you up
monday takes you monday
initiated contact okay it's okay
to initiate contact with her on tuesday
but the thing is you want to make
statements all right
not conversation so theoretically if
it's me
i hit her up on tuesday and i say hey
good afternoon
uh have a productive day don't work too
hard talk to you later something like
that i made a statement i don't say hey
what's for lunch all right
you know now she started that then
that's fine
but i'm gonna make a statement all right
because i don't want her to think i'm
needy all right
so you don't want a woman start thinking
you needy like you need conversation
like you know
so you're gonna make a statement because
she initiated this is probably good
advice for short-term relationships that
are
casual but if you're looking to like get
married have a long-term relationship
and you want to play like texting games
like no that's that's a no for me
contact so you initiated contact this is
for high interest you ain't gonna even
get no [ __ ] out of this i don't know low
entrance women all right you you can
forget about it you're gonna get no [ __ ]
like this out of
low low-inch women you're gonna be doing
all the pursuing 100 but
the high interest woman is okay to go
back and forth now here's the thing
don't initiate contact twice in a
[ __ ] day
ever so if i hit her up initially
on tuesday
and okay she asked me okay thank you
uh have a productive day also i'm not
gonna hit her back 6 p.m
so how was your day or i hope you had a
wonderful day i'm just getting home
[ __ ] no no no no no no no
no see now you're going the wrong way
all right now you're showing too much
high interest
and now her interest don't start going
this way all right so you want to assure
that you are interested but you don't
want her to start seeing you got two
higher interest all right
so now she's gonna start losing interest
all right because she's starting to see
you where you stand she's starting to
see you like her a whole lot all right
so you don't want to show that you like
that goddamn much so initiate contact
one time per day all right one time per
day
now you guys already know no emojis no
feminine text
and no [ __ ] like that all right now
here's the thing guys
don't initiate contact
uh two consecutive times so let's
hypothetically say you hit her up on
tuesday good
good afternoon hope you have a
productive day and she responded that
and then she don't text you wednesday
and then you text her
initiate contact again on thursday no no
no no no no
we ain't gonna initiate contact no more
until
uh she initiate contact also on that
second time when you initiate contact on
tuesday you can go and ask her out
all right so you can go ask her out for
uh what's up
oh my god okay this is what i mean
when i say like like people always want
to talk about like
women getting like played or whatever
and
or like women choosing the [ __ ] like
men can see through other men's like you
know all of this nonsense and like [ __ ]
a lot better than women can because one
women are emotional
and two women start dating and like
getting attention at like an earlier
age and so you're asking like a
six you start dating like what 16 i was
older i was like
19. but like
like 16 17 18 19 like 20 year olds whose
brains aren't even done developing to
like be able to have the wisdom and the
character to like
sort through this like nonsense
like oh my goodness
this guy i mean he seems like
i don't know how to put it like he seems
like he's open and honest
with the people that he dates that he's
dating multiple women that's just not
like the type of person that personally
like
i think would be a good person to
instill like values in your children
and like like kindness compassion
whatever
availability i always ask a girl for
what's her availability guys i always
ask a woman
what's her availability all right that
way you don't get boxed in and seeming
to available and what i mean by that
let's hypothetically say you say tuesday
you asked her out and you say hey are
you available saturday
and she said i got a party saturday and
now she's like but i'm open
friday you see how available you seem
you see how you don't box yourself
in as in looking like you ain't have
[ __ ] to do this weekend
all right and you accept friday she can
lose interest all right so always ask a
girl what's availability she might say
something to the effect of on free
thursday evening
and saturday evening all right and pick
which of those days that fit your
schedule
all right but don't just uh try to offer
a girl
a date all right i always ask her her
availability i
i should i meant to ben tell you guys
this all right but
you know that's not bad advice
like why some bad advice i haven't been
told you guys this
because i i just got back to dayton all
right i told you guys i've been on my
purpose for like this last seven months
and so i just got back to dayton and i i
asked the women what's their
availability and i was like i gotta
remember to tell the guys because i just
been dating my same old girls all right
so i just got to dating you know
different girls
and i made sure that i make sure i tell
you guys always ask a girl her
availability
don't ask her are you free saturday
because if she say hey i got a friend
party on saturday
now you [ __ ] boxed in because she
might say one free sunday
and then you're like okay so oh so you
had [ __ ] to do the whole [ __ ] weekend
you [ __ ] loser
all right so then she started thinking
like well maybe he'll look as good as i
thought he looked
he looked cute but you know if he was
that cute why would he be available the
whole [ __ ] weekend all right so
always
what okay i wouldn't i think
what's your availability is a good idea
because then
like for the reason he's sad like it's a
lot easier to set up plans when you know
when she's available
instead of but
i don't i don't think it's a big deal
if you want to switch it from one day to
the other
please ask a woman what's her
availability all right that way you
don't box yourself in very important
guys to keep your value up
all right the whole point with a high
interest girl is we always trying to
keep our value up she sees us
we do it for her the way we walk for
whatever she see the confidence and see
see the swag
you don't want her to go to start [ __ ]
testing you when she start doubting your
value
being available the whole [ __ ]
weekend anybody gonna start about
debating your value what's your value
and when i say value
your sexual market value what i mean by
sexual what i tell you guys about sexual
market value
it's not about how much money you got
it's not about how big your house is
it's not about how many abs you got
it's about how many other how many other
women won't you
that what determines your sexual market
value in other words
if you 400 pounds and you live with your
[ __ ] mama
but every girl in your city want to [ __ ]
you you got a high sexual market value
all right
it don't matter what i think i'm a dude
you're trying to [ __ ] me it don't matter
if i think you got low sexual market
value
women determine your sexual market value
so if you 400 pounds
and every girl in the town want to [ __ ]
you and you work at mcdonald's
they don't give a [ __ ] what i think i'm
not [ __ ] you it matters what women
think
women determines what your sexual market
value is
so if she perceives you as other women
keeping you occupied then she your
sexual market value is high
if you that's not completely true though
because
um i there's definitely been times where
i've stopped talking
to someone because i feel like he's
talking to too many girls
like you free the whole [ __ ] weekend
how much sexual market value you could
you have i want you guys to just think
about it all right
you so [ __ ] high value that you got
the whole [ __ ] weekend available
i'm in a high value you think leonardo
dicaprio got a whole [ __ ] weekend
available
huh you think that you think jamie foxx
got the whole [ __ ] weekend available
huh you think he don't got nothing to do
with no other girls and then that's
going on he's just free the whole
[ __ ] weekend he's just sitting around
the house with nothing to do on the
[ __ ] weekend
huh y'all think justin bieber ain't got
nothing to do the whole [ __ ] weekend
free the whole [ __ ] weekend all right
so if you put yourself in a position
where you available
the whole [ __ ] weekend or you show
you so too available the woman starts
gotten your sexual market value she
started thinking like
well i thought he was hot but i guess
the other women don't make you hot so
then you start looking less attractive
to her
because women attraction to you is based
off
what other women see you so in other
words like this guys
when you go out with a woman she's
watching other women
to see if they scoping you out all right
so
you know a lot of times y'all guys be on
dates with women and [ __ ]
and you're wondering like where the
interest went well she went out with you
and she
see no other women scoping you out all
right so her interest for you drop
so y'all guys got to be aware that when
a woman goes somewhere with you
and all the when you walk in the room
and all eyes on you
oh man her answers will go up like damn
hey they want this [ __ ] yo but
she could take you somewhere
out and y'all go to a club or a lounge
or whatever the case may be
and she look around and like you know
she's just walking straight ahead and
she don't see women like you know she
see you don't turn heads
how interesting you gonna drop that's
just the bottom [ __ ] line guys i
don't know another way that's played
if you i don't really care if other
girls
think the guy that i'm dating is true i
love the woman and you start turning
heads
she can have low interest in you watch
what happened to an interest
because she see other women won't you
all right so that's the bottom line with
that guys women determine your sexual
market value
so if you're too available then
obviously you ain't got many other women
which means that you got low sexual
market value all right that's the bottom
[ __ ] line
so you know this thing dog i'm like
tired over it like this is overthinking
it too much for me this [ __ ] guys is
instinctive
they don't think about it and [ __ ] like
this this [ __ ] is instinctive all right
so that's the bottom line with that
all right let me make sure i ain't
forgotten them so
is i longest as long as she's still
pursuing
say you text her tuesday she hit you
wednesday initiate contact
and it's okay for you to do thursday all
right that's the bottom line with that
now
the low interest woman uh
let me make sure hold up one second let
me get my notes all right so
this [ __ ] here ain't gonna do nothing
all right
she got [ __ ] low interest all right
so you need to know that route the back
she ain't gonna do nothing you gotta do
every [ __ ] thing
all right the little selfish [ __ ] all
right so here's the thing guys
for whatever reason physically or
whatever reason your personality
whatever
she ain't blown the [ __ ] way and i
know some of you guys
might think you want to walk away from
these guys listen that
i would say at least 50 to 60
of the women you go out with is gonna
have lower interest all right
now if she's willing to go on a date
with you that means that you
you you she can see herself [ __ ] you
all right
she can see herself [ __ ] [ __ ] you
but you gotta raise her interest and for
you guys say
oh it might be an attention i'm gonna
tell you guys something attention horror
don't go on a date with you
attention [ __ ] do everything but set a
[ __ ] date
all right it's the difference between a
woman with low interest and attention
[ __ ]
this is true well okay i'm not i'm gonna
ignore the attention [ __ ] part
but like sometimes when you meet a guy
or like when people like meet someone
they may not be super interested in the
beginning but
a lot of guys can like play the long
game
and end up like winning a girl over that
maybe wasn't super interested
in the beginning the one attention [ __ ]
would
try to do everything to use you for your
non-sexual attention
but won't set a [ __ ] date the girl
with low interest which is just a step
above the attention [ __ ]
i mean just a slight step above
attention or well
she sees you she she can possibly have
sex with you
but you got a long way to go to get her
entrance up all right in the bottom line
like this guys
if you got a woman with low interest you
just didn't raise some interest and
that's fine you know ain't nobody gonna
lose no sleep
by not raising no [ __ ] interest but you
did a horrible job
over raising her interest and frankly
if you got a lot of options maybe you
don't even care my thing is
uh i want to [ __ ] them too all right
because my
listen guys if you over here just the
[ __ ] high interest [ __ ]
man listen unpledge right now and save
your [ __ ] money that's what you
paying me for the [ __ ] [ __ ] that got
high
interest okay just just two seconds do
you guys see this as someone who's gonna
have a long happy successful marriage
he might get a lot of girls or whatever
like
teach like alpha mentality whatever but
just because you can get a lot of girls
that doesn't mean
you're going to have a long happy
successful marriage
hey what you paying five dollars for you
paying five dollars just so you can [ __ ]
[ __ ] who got high interest
that's what you're doing you need me to
teach you how to [ __ ] a [ __ ] that got
high interest in you
really that's what you're paying you
wasting your [ __ ] money the whole
point
of alpha male strategies is to get
[ __ ] that are on the fence
not [ __ ] that see you as a [ __ ]
demon god all right that's the [ __ ]
point guys
we wanna learn we gotta you gotta learn
how to [ __ ] [ __ ] who don't
exactly panties get wet when they
[ __ ] see you if all you ever wanna
[ __ ] in your life
is [ __ ] who got crazy high initial
interest then what the [ __ ] you
following me for
what's the point the point is i'm
teaching you guys
how to get these [ __ ] that are on the
fence anybody can [ __ ] a [ __ ] that got
high interest [ __ ]
hey you know how bad you gotta [ __ ] up
the [ __ ] busy with high interest
man you know how bad you gotta be man
you gotta like trip and fall on a date
ten times
you gotta over pursue to the max man you
got so much [ __ ] room for errol with
a [ __ ] that see you as a nine or ten
that is [ __ ] ridiculous i hope ain't
none of you guys over here just to learn
how to [ __ ] [ __ ]
that got high interest i'm i'm teaching
you guys how to [ __ ] these [ __ ] that
see you as a
five six and a seven
oh my goodness like
this just seems tiring to me not a
eight nine and ten you don't need me for
that [ __ ] hell
yeah you know why you probably a [ __ ]
that see you as eight nine ten probably
you probably set the first date
to come to your house and help [ __ ]
netflix and chill that's easy
i want you to [ __ ] those listen i told
you guys
when i was uh came to youtube
i was already [ __ ] down 25 women a
year
but i left a lot of ass on the table
because i couldn't [ __ ] the [ __ ]
who was lukewarm interest i didn't need
no i didn't need to learn game and [ __ ]
and improve my game to [ __ ] those 25
[ __ ]
they just saw me as god so it's easy for
me not to [ __ ] it up
what i wanted to know was those [ __ ]
that i that was on the fence
i wanted to know how to [ __ ] those and i
would have some girls that would have
crazy high initial interest and they
would and i would lose it
i want to learn from you but that was
real most of the time i wanted to just
know how to [ __ ]
the [ __ ] that would that would go on
a date with me one or two dates and then
they'll fizzle out
i want to know how to improve my game to
[ __ ] them i ain't need nobody
i ain't need to learn no damn game to
learn how to [ __ ] a girl to see me as a
nine [ __ ] i could be homeless on the
[ __ ] street
and [ __ ] that [ __ ] all right so
oh my goodness ah guys like this
like kind caring compassionate
that
he's like calling these girls [ __ ] like
i don't even know what to say i want you
guys to know game to [ __ ] these [ __ ]
for you guys
i ain't [ __ ] with no little [ __ ]
man i ain't got time for that and what
the [ __ ]
always you need me to teach you how to
[ __ ] a girl that see you as a nine or
ten
man you got a badge you gotta [ __ ] up
the [ __ ] up with a girl that see you as
a nine or ten that's what i'm here for
they teach you how to [ __ ] these
[ __ ] all right so
first thing you need to know guys is you
ask availability and [ __ ] like that when
you make the text
she ain't gonna do no pursuing now
here's the thing guys
with this one right here she sees you as
um
low interest so no double texan
no double texting this is big with the
low entrance girl
because you'll text her five hours six
hours seven hours
this [ __ ] takes you back the next day
sometimes all right
never double text now here's the thing
guys
i don't know how you would do it but
there's a way you can like
i feel like i've had back when i was on
dating apps i have a boyfriend now but
like
when a guy would like double text me but
in a way that made it like funny
and like basically call me out for not
texting the first time
i don't know that like works because a
lot especially on dating apps like
there's so many people messaging you
that when you get someone that's a
little bit like sassy it's kind of like
stands out a little bit don't get butt
hurt off of her slow response
or her next day text i'm telling you
it's going to come all right
one thing i'm trying to get you guys
over is to start getting butt hurt
because a girl don't got high enough
interest when she just dropped down and
start sucking your dick on the first
date all right
i'm trying to get y'all guys over that
[ __ ] where your butt hurt because a
girl
ain't blowing your phone up and showing
crazy how i am get over that [ __ ]
all right
so this girl got lower interest she
might text you the next day
you butt hurt you mad you don't want to
respond you want to block a number
because she took nick that call you
little baby you would get a bill and
wipe your tears and she took the next
day to call you and she got no interest
in me
she took me
okay you [ __ ] [ __ ] listen
the bottom line is this right here guys
the woman has lower interest in you
so you somewhere the bottom of the totem
pole keep the [ __ ] dates cheap
so you don't put your investment into
her because of the good chance
that she just feels things just fills a
lot but the thing is if you display high
value techniques
you go out you stay in your masculine
frame you own your
i will say the worst thing a guy can do
when he gets rejected is like
to complain about it i will agree with
him and then
if they keep doing their own thing and
just like following their hobbies and
whatever
you some girls will come around not all
but some girls do
purpose which means that you're going to
be able to pass all her [ __ ] tests one
of the [ __ ] test is
double texting because she's going to
take her time responding to your text
because for some reason whatever the
case may be she doubts your value
i don't know why but she doubts the
value maybe it's something you said or
did
but she kind of or maybe you just don't
do it for her physically
it don't it don't really [ __ ] matter
but you
she got low interest in you and that's
fine but if you do the alpha male
scratches until
you know hold the masculine frame pass
the [ __ ] test
don't over pursue this woman will get
will warm up to you
i'm telling you that right now this
woman will warm up to you the girl
that i my sunday piece i asked that
comes over here now
on our first date how did these girls
watch these videos and still continue to
come over
oh my god and that was before i you know
this was when i was you know listening
uh
you know this was you know because i
figured out a lot of strategies
myself so i would you know i would do
what the other day coaches say i would
kiss on the first date and [ __ ] go for
the kids on the first day she kissed me
like this on the first date
and now my dick in her mouth for an hour
to every [ __ ] sunday
alright so if i would have went by that
kissing expression
and not raising her interest i would
have said
oh she got a little interest because she
kissed me like a fish
she kissed me literally like this when i
went to kiss her when we walked out the
pool hall
she kissed me like this
that's how she kissed me all right like
she didn't want to
i knew i could raise up her interest i
knew i now my dick in her mouth
for one or two hours every sunday all
right i never initiate contact she calls
me all she texts me all through the week
asking me constantly when can i call her
[ __ ] like this here my dick is in her
mouth
my balls in her mouth uh every [ __ ]
sunday i stopped making her lick my ass
because she's proved her loyalty to me
and she's very submissive to me or
whatever case so i don't i don't upgrade
her from ass liquor status to now it's
just ball sucking status so she'll
oh my god why
why do these girls want you're one of
many
that's so degrading as a woman like that
be with a guy that talks about you like
this
you just stayed up and the bottom line
is i'm saying like this guys
this was a girl that often i didn't
knock her socks off on the first date
all right but i knew how to raise her
interest you get what i'm saying
i had the game in the in the in the swag
and i was on my purpose i knew how to
raise the entrance and now my dick is in
my mouth
for two hours every day on sunday y'all
get what i'm going okay so don't worry
about a girl not blown away by you on
the first [ __ ] date
small caveat i do agree with that some
girls it takes a second for them to come
around
i'm here to teach you guys how to [ __ ]
these [ __ ] too alright and another
thing you might get with these girls
when you ask her what's her availability
and [ __ ] like that she might say some
[ __ ] to the effect of
i might be able to do friday she might
text you some [ __ ] like that might be
able to do friday
don't get emotional don't get mad oh i
don't do
you just text back might with a question
mark
that's that's a good response
no i don't you know let them know i
don't understand what might mean
all right most times when i do that to a
girl with low interest or whatever
they'll say lol yeah i'm free friday on
free saturday all right
yeah so that's how you handle that might
[ __ ] when a girl say
might or i i cannot ch can i uh
i might be able to that's usually what
you'll hear through the text it's the
word might
i always text back might with a question
mark and i'll put parentheses around
that [ __ ] love what the hell is mike
all right so that's the bottom line with
that guys so that's the bottom line with
this video guys
you got high interest text and you got
low interest text and like i teach like
i tell you guys
before you disqualify the low interest
girls the whole point of you over here
is the [ __ ]
these [ __ ] all right you gotta [ __ ]
up so bad to [ __ ] up the low entrance
and i'm teaching you guys now how not to
lower these girls inches too
but a girl that goes guys a girl who
goes out any girl that goes out on a
date with you
she got somewhat interested in you
that's true
she's not an attention horror attention
war you can't get on a date attention
while you try to set dates and they call
and text but they want to go on they
won't go on a date
they just hey how your day going it's
going okay you're free you free this
weekend
uh can i get back with you that's an
attention or attention or don't go on a
date with you
she might see me have very okay i think
i get the idea
um he had a couple caveats that i would
agree with
but at the end of the day like
people like this just worship themselves
like they
live as themselves as god don't think
about other people
very selfish you can live like that
that's totally fine
um it just like personally wouldn't be
something that i would
be like want to date so some girls will
put up with that stuff
but i would never tell a girl to like
date a guy like that
anyways let me know in the comments if
you agree or disagree don't forget to
like comment and subscribe